- Thank you.
Thank you. (chuckles)
(audience cheers and applauds)
Hello, everybody. Wow.
Welcome to "The Kelly Clarkson Show."
My name is Kumail Nanjiani Clarkson.
(audience laughs)
Don't have my wife I changed my name
to be able to guest host this show.
So hopefully she doesn't watch.
(audience laughs)
It was worth it, I think.
So, thank you for coming.
I'm very sorry, she's not feeling well.
I'll be here and I'll be less
than half as good as she is.
But you're gonna give me the love, right?
(audience cheers and applauds)
Thank you. Thank you.
So Kelly always starts with
music, but I am not musical.
(audience laughs)
I cannot dance. I am tone deaf.
So here's a Kellyoke Encore.
Check out Kelly and her band
Y'all with Lizzo's "Juice."
(audience cheers and applauds)
(upbeat music)
♪ No, I'm not a snack at all ♪
♪ Look, baby, I'm the whole damn meal ♪
♪ Ooh, baby ♪
♪ Baby, you ain't being slick ♪
♪ Don't dare try to cop a feel ♪
♪ Ooh, baby ♪
♪ The juice ain't worth the squeeze ♪
♪ If the juice don't look like this ♪
♪ Like this, like this, like this ♪
♪ Hey, hold on, baby, please ♪
♪ Don't make me have to take your bish ♪
♪ How I roll ♪
♪ If I'm shining, everybody gonna shine ♪
♪ Yeah, I'm goals ♪
♪ I was born like this,
don't even gotta try ♪
♪ Now you know ♪
♪ I'm like Chardonnay,
get better over time ♪
♪ So you know ♪
♪ I heard you say I'm not
the baddest, ooh, you lie ♪
♪ You lie ♪
♪ It ain't my fault that
I'm out here getting loose ♪
♪ Gotta blame it on the Goose ♪
♪ Gotta blame it on my juice, baby ♪
♪ It ain't my fault that
I'm out here making news ♪
♪ I'm the pudding in the proof ♪
♪ Gotta blame it on my juice ♪
♪ Ya-ya-ee ♪
♪ Ya-ya-ee, ya-ya-ee ♪
♪ Whoo ♪
♪ Ya-ya-ee ♪
♪ Blame it on my juice, blame
it, blame it on my juice ♪
♪ Ya-ya-ee ♪
♪ Ya-ya-ee, ya-ya-ee ♪
♪ Blame it on my juice, blame
it, blame it on my juice ♪
♪ Ya-ya-ee ♪
♪ Somebody come get this man ♪
♪ I think he got lost in my DMs, what ♪
♪ You better come get your man ♪
♪ I think he wanna be
way more than friends ♪
♪ What you want me to say, hey ♪
♪ It ain't my fault that
I'm out here getting loose ♪
♪ I'm the pudding in the proof ♪
♪ Gotta blame on my juice, come on ♪
♪ Ya-ya-ee ♪
♪ Ya-ya-ee, ya-ya-ee ♪
♪ I'm the juice, blame
it, blame it on my juice ♪
♪ Ya-ya-ee ♪
(audience cheers and applauds)
(Kelly laughs)
- Give it up again for Kelly and Y'all.
(audience cheers and applauds)